hi guys welcome to ask I J I'm so
excited for this episode but I'm having
a lot of trouble shooting it because I
can't get the song out of my head I
don't know how I've never seen this
video is by parry Gripp and it was
posted last year and as are 7 million
views
[Music]
now one of the biggest questions that I
get on this show is why did you have a
big black mark on your wall I'm sorry
it's taken care of I used some whiteout
I did actually meet Axl Rose and I
didn't film anything I kind of went up
to him took a picture and I really
didn't have anything to say to each
other so I just kind of turned around
and walked away
don't leave it crashing no my hair is
not naturally red do I like Shane Dawson
like like thumbs up like like how do you
work this thing isn't that just a pen
what's on my walls do you really want to
know those are wigs
Lester dancing in an Apple store in
Chicago I've been Jenny up a store in
Chicago but I did not dance in Chicago
for a froot what would I be passionfruit
hey guys it's me I just seen my
celebrity crush is it illegal to say
Justin Bieber because I'm not sure about
that Katrina how long will I be making
videos probably for the rest of my life
you will probably see me walking around
in a little walker vlogging Rugrats have
I ever broken an Apple product and not
been able to get it fixed
well there was that time that I smashed
my iPhone
[Music]
you go away well go away that's cool how
did I get so awesome you'll have to
thank my parents for that because
they're pretty cool I'm gonna gigabyte
memory cards do I using my camera I
usually carry around with me a 16 and
naked
did I ever finish school did my laundry
I did a live show the other day and you
guys all came and watched me attempt to
put my laundry throws laundry I'm gonna
fold it but it's pretty unsuccessful but
most of it um yeah no I didn't actually
finish in the last episode I asked you
guys as the question of the video what
was the most romantic or the worst thing
that anyone has ever done for you I
don't know what happened but none of you
guys seemed to really answer this
question but this is probably one of my
favorite answers from leap out of state
here someone said that they would wait
for me to be old enough and then marry
me what's the worst thing he was drunk
yeah sorry about that one thank you guys
so much for watching this episode of ask
I J be sure to check out the last video
that I posted then I'll see you guys in
the next episode peace that was a piece
this was a bye
[Music]